we learned one thing last night the
media is the disease and Donald Trump is
the cure I mean truly dishonest people
in the media and the fake media they
make up stories I'm really doing this to
show you how damn dishonest these people
are I mean CNN is really bad but ABC
this morning I don't watch it much but
I'm watching in the morning and they
have little George Stephanopoulos
talking to nikki Haley right little Joe
it's time to expose the crooked media
deceptions and to challenge the media
for their role in fermenting division
and yes by the way they are trying to
take away our history and our heritage
these are sick people a little George it
got better
Trump taped an infomercial for fnc
knowing that it's airing on CNN I must
tell you
Fox has treated me fairly [ __ ]
someday they might not treat me fairly
and I'll tell you about it okay
but they've treated me fairly and I
don't mean all good I get plenty of bad
on Fox too but at least it's within
reason and Hannity how good is Hannity
he said and he's a great guy and he's an
honest guy and Fox and Friends in the
morning is the best show and it's the
absolute most honest show and it's the
show I watch Fox and Friends a poor
man's five that we were the Armstrong of
time your days are numbered you even
have days our number in honey when we
store it I know anyway you got to admit
that is awesome trolling plugging fnc on
CNN
that's like ordering a coke at the Pepsi
Factory now by now we know Trump's peel
the media makes a big deal out of
nothing it craps a redwood from an acorn
but just before his rally ESPN proved
him right they pulled a reporter from a
UVA game because his name was Robert Lee
yeah it sounded too close to Sarah Lee
and there
pound cake goes straight to your hips
actually they were worried his name
might cause teasing because of the fuss
over statues how sad protecting a grown
man from jokes his ESPN still a Sports
Network
what's the sport patty-cake talk about
hysteria and it supports Trump's media
analysis when you react preemptively
over a cowardly fear of something that
doesn't exist you are broken and the
media thinks Trump's unstable ESPN is
trapped in a mirage where all things are
viewed irrationally because the poor
saps are held hostage to fear note
they're not literally held hostage just
a figure of speech so what's next
ESPN banned words like monumental or
statuesque what about players named
Jefferson or Davis but really this story
is a healthy sign once expose everyone
did laugh at it but it leads me to one
question does ESPN still cover sports or
just their asses kill me Donald Trump
president Trump gushing about Fox's
grass hi when you heard you heard him do
that did you hide yourself in the mirror
of your lonely sad hotel room it's just
a bit of a surreal experience the
president stays in front of the capacity
crowd in Phoenix go chronicling your
show yeah I expect that they work it was
crowded my fully expect my mom to do
that yeah it does like Fox and Princeton
she has a lot of choices she gets all
the channels yeah it's the full bags I
don't know why because she doesn't even
know she has movie channels but I just
say that in the real experience but that
that's what Donald Trump is he's
absolutely transparent in that he
watched toward 7 apples give an
interview after an Afghanistan policy
about a war we've been fighting and
trying to win he got one question out
and was back to 8 days later with
Charlottesville he's being honest George
Stephanopoulos how do I hurt his
feelings comment on his height so there
you go so what else do I have in my mind
I watched I start the day on Fox &
Friends and I like those guys yeah so I
just know Donald Trump as being somebody
who speaks the truth who agrees with my
mom I can I never I could never be
President cuz I could I could never say
what I started my day you would say I
was right I was still on you don't know
what that means
you know why should should the NFL
continue using Dixie Cups on the
sidelines Dixie Cups yes that's a good
question that's about the equivalent
your mom yes that's how serious and fake
hard-hitting news here what do you make
of my connection between ESPN and Trump
to that ESPN somehow proved him right by
they're kind of like a radical thinking
yeah I don't think I don't think they
proved him right to any extent but I
think it was you know right before the
speech and I think the conservative echo
chamber exploded I mean what use you
brought it up here I'm part of that was
echo chamber America the youth odias pin
was out of control no no I think it's an
absurd crazy decision on the face of it
now there's a statement out from the
ESPN in which they said it had nothing
to do with anybody being offended by
Robert Lee announcing the Virginia games
that in fact it was about that whether
or not there would be memes and
hectoring and there was a teasing of
Robert a teasing of Robert Lee and that
Robert Lee Wilkinson heckling yes by the
way I'm gonna go easy on ESPN that might
have to work their way the fortune
teller saw her can over here please
oh my goodness I got my eyes on your
seat I'm John Kimberly you're a canoe
barbecue by watch it's a bunt one buys
the excuse that they were protecting him
from being teased god I mean I don't
think would anybody protect you from to
you as an announcer anyone ever nobody
protect you okay getting me I'm like I'm
like the dartboard it's like the local
you know Deadliest Catch bar um anyway
know what I think though is that they
were protecting themselves they're not
protecting Robert Lee they want to act
like they're altruistic and we're just
looking out for this guy and trying to
protect our employee I don't think
that's the case I think they're worried
that ESPN was going to take criticism
and it was going to be another bad round
of publicity for them but oops that
actually happened anyway because of the
way they had it and then all day long
you saw everyone putting up the picture
of Robert Lee like such a nice guy poor
thing and you know it's on and on and
now people are making fun of ESPN and
saying like they have kind of no compass
their compass is whether or not it might
be bad press right but what about what's
the right thing the most famous
sportscaster there's been there since
day one his name is
Bob Lee why did he escape me that's what
why was why when are they trying to pick
him from a mean always go by the short
nickname like not the fool I just hate
it when cable networks catching a bad
controversy hey Dana doesn't this story
reveal the difference between the
perception of possible outrage in real
outrage and I think that we operate the
media by possible outrage we're
constantly worried about what we'll get
to say I self-edit yeah you have a
filthy mind and I actually do think okay
III think that they were overthinking it
yes yeah and I think they made a
terrible decision and I was the first to
say this is the most ridiculous story
yeah but III think that they probably
were when they got around the conference
they probably have consultants who
called in like charging them a lot of
money to sit around and say we should
really try to protect him yeah because
he's going to be the subject of all of
these insults on Twitter and I could I
could actually by that I don't think
they would necessarily happen here I
think that they went way overboard
because every action causes his
overreaction in this situation but Megan
McArdle in Bloomberg at Bloomberg she
wrote a piece today said that we're all
afraid of the online mob so that you are
making decisions and editing yourself
before you can even get anything out
because you don't you're afraid of the
social media backlash when actually if
you turn it off it doesn't exist no it's
it's like a cloudy day if you just look
away you don't see the routes that's
your way you want to know how I do it
why don't you have a pen handy don't try
this yes okay what I do is I forget my
password so I don't log on I have no
idea what your password is not password
not anymore
and it's true I don't I oh I know what
it does I heart do see wait like know
what I Club do see we're not really sure
but put it this way it would be more
likely to be Angley yeah but it that way
I could give away my password but I
actually I have not bothered by things I
don't know yeah I am right I lived a lot
of the next step yeah I believe you
living my life yeah I have no idea what
so many people are going to start
walking away at least run on the Twitter
side of mass because there's not enough
room for context I'd retweeted something
that micro wrote today on Facebook in
response to somebody who caught a white
nationalist and his response is so
thoughtful but it takes a lot
for him to explain it so he does it on
Facebook I thought Tucker Carlson
tonight he said that he basically took
Twitter off of all of his devices and
this is actually the next step in all of
this which is just walk away you should
try to walk away from it you said to
people and I even I would include
wantonness are happier people you don't
you don't read your ad mentions on
Twitter I don't see you ever looking at
anything she doesn't know how yeah I
know how but I'm just saying something I
mean it gets pretty nasty yeah ignore it
but yeah but yeah but I must say that
you do feel at times like you know what
people find out things there's gossip
yep mostly trashy gossip or someone
putting someone down yeah a lot of
that's going on and I just say well it's
a bathroom wall that never ends I was
like it for the like to monitor breaking
news or to rebut what I would have said
I got rid and the reformed Jewish
Journal I believe that Bethenny Mandel
had tweeted and I never would have seen
that before but it was about this
security guard at the in Charlottesville
that was guarding the synagogue and how
a retired naval officer came over and
helped him to be able to protect it not
that's something I never would have seen
in my course of my destroyers
consumption that's a but I don't like to
look at the comments no and I think
that's the best part of it I love
Twitter for that because you can get an
access it's like a really great way to
aggregate and get all the different you
know articles and but you know the cheap
shots are just when I thought I thought
I was the one who was you said to
Kimberly that I was making excuses when
I said they were reacting to this and
worried about him but in fact now all of
you are saying well this this social
media thing drives people and they are
too quick to react if you are trying to
expose our hypocrisy how dare you know
we're not going to work it's not too
late today create let's transition on to
something else
any thoughts on over we're gonna talk
about the media response and the B block
any thoughts on the rally rally the
rally yesterday a lot different than
today's speech in Nevada a lot different
from Monday's I think that the president
was pleased with the rally and that's
probably most important I really curious
to see we're this where this whole thing
goes because he has not provided the
screaming headlines for his enemies like
he has in past weeks they're going to
to work for the controversy this week
Dana I'd say his basis with him no
matter what so again I go back to you
have this opportunity you could drive
one thing the most important thing on
his legislative agenda for the fall is
tax reform unless it's the wall I mean
it could be maybe that maybe he thinks
that the wall is the most important
thing but the house has already put it
in the budget and funded it so I don't
think you need to wait some time so it's
tax reform so if it's tax reform and you
have capacity crowd in Arizona and
there's screaming fans and you say
here's what I want I want tax reform and
I wanted my on my desk by November first
and here's what I want in it and this is
why it's going to help all of you now
help me get there I think that would be
a better use of his time I think that
the bashing of the media in some ways
like I don't get it but there's no way
to drive a headline and then again like
the action over reaction
it's a nitpicking on both sides it's
just I know that it's probably not
healthier positive but I kind of enjoy
it wand does that make me a weak person
no you mean but it's like Pro Wrestling
you like it's just like entertaining
your little George yeah he labels people
it's let me imagine if Obama did that to
you
oh did he have to box but otherwise no
no I think what did he do he block or
Saturday Night Live was not there
Washington correspondent
it have been over we man play you on
Saturday Night Live remember that and I
had him removed he's all around okay
that's what happened somebody do that
exercise program project something I'm
really actually got green I got it yeah
let me let me just quickly jump in say
that I thought that he was reacting
throughout much of the speech last night
to what had happened with the
Charlottesville stuff yeah and so he's
going after the press he's pulling out
the speech out of him saying oh I said
this like he he doesn't mention he said
both sides and then he and then he has
this guy behind him and I found this guy
tremendously entertaining as a black guy
with holding up a sign black support
Trump and on and then today you find out
this guy's twice been accused of murder
he's member of a cult he's saying
Obama's the Beast and Hillary's some
other now who hasn't done that but I
mean which so this is the guy behind the
President of the United States it's not
literally behind has it well that's more
of a there's somebody behind they should
vet and make sure that there aren't
people here
oh I thought you were going to do a Greg
and tell me it was I don't remember
there were some Americas apparent help
somebody's I was going with it
Omar Mike yeah bad and if the Hillary
Clinton yeah I don't want to I don't
want to mix my backs up because I've
done that enough of that right you were
correct okay Omar matine's dad I think
you should quit while you glory all
right